hélène buzzati luc ferrandez christian
dufour bonsoir bonsoir on revient sur le
rapport de la coroner parce
qu'aujourd'hui on apprend que la grande
patronne du sus de l'ouest vote
démissionné en fait officiellement ne va
pas renouveler son mandat une merveille
on va écouter monsieur legault sur la
notion d'imputabilité
on revient je comprends jura passe
quelque chose qui sont passés après que
le suisse a pris le contrôle du ch celle
des donc c'est pas l'information j'avais
ça doit être plus clair que faute
imputable de ce conte ce que met
le premier ministre lui-même le ministre
l'a senti peut pas commencer à s'assurer
de jerry ce qui se passe dans chacun des
établissements de santé au québec donc
ce qu'il faut qu'une délégation de
pouvoir puis quand quelqu'un j'ai pas
bien
il faut changer le gestionnaire
il faut changer gestionnaire christian
je vais commencer avec vous passez
souvent vous dites et des rapports
paient jamais rien qui valent la voix
voici que la coronaire et encore une
fois elle ne m'a jamais deviné pas la
coupable de ce rapport l'appui tous les
os mais la désorganisation du sud de
l'ouest est montré du doigt on donne des
exemples etc qu'est ce que vous avez
pensé de sa décision de partir et du
rapport
je trouve que c'est bien le moins qu'ils
aient un minimum d'habitabilité par
rapport à cette catastrophe moi je
regrette quand même que la coroner
donner des plus d'habileté politique ont
des dents régime parlementaire ou quand
des drames comme ça arrive que s'ils y
avaient assemblé truc ça n'existe plus
il y avait la responsabilité
ministérielle et même si les ministres
n'étaient pas en soit responsable de ce
qui est arrivé dans son ministère qui
peut amener à démissionner aucune
responsabilité pour le site moi ça m'a
beaucoup déçu dans ce rapport là qu'elle
est pas du tout assumer de
responsabilités aux policiers une
régression pour le fait pas mais c'est
bien loin
la pdg de monsieur ce démissionne mais
je trouve que monsieur legault sentir
bien il offense et
bizarrement complètement mais c'était
quand même son gouvernement qui est
éloquent ce drame de lui qu'est ce que
vous avez pensé et de la nouvelle
d'aujourd'hui et ce où vous voulez aller
plus largement sur ce rapport qui
christian le souligner à sa façon mais
qui a étonné plusieurs personnes on
croyait que madame kamel al être plus
durs entre guillemets envers les
décisions politiques ce n'est pas le cas
elle a cherché des solutions sur la
politique c'est le disent il faut
séparer la capacité opérationnelle
de l'adedy stratégique c'est à dire
quand même des torts donne un ordre il
peut pas en même temps être celui qui
vivifie cela aura été fait alors que
propose cette séparation là notamment la
santé publique mais moi je trouve que
c'est très pratique pour monsieur le
goût de parler de décentralisation bien
sûr la décentralisation bien sûr des
habiletés tout le monde et pau il faut
pas clair il faut que ça y est que la
bureaucratie soit le moins la moins
lourde possible ceci étant dit c'est un
problème de ressources les ressources
humaines alors les problèmes de
ressources humaines sont gérés par des
conventions collectives sont révèles jeu
gérés par des ressources conférée par
l'état et donc le salaire par exemple
des préposés aux bénéficiaires et fixes
et des conditions sont fixes d même
chose pour les infirmières même chose
pour les ententes avec les médecins
qu'est-ce qui reste à gérer sur le
terrain les horaires aussi sur a6 fixe
il reste pas tant que ça de marge pour
avoir donné potabilité alors je trouve
que c'est très pratique comme discours
pour monsieur legault
oui mais c'était à peu près inévitable
que cette dame offre sa démission après
la déclaration de monsieur legault et je
suis assez d'accord que monsieur legault
et son équipe s'en tire assez bien ceci
dit même si le principe des
habilité ministériel dont christian
parler est effectivement très important
le fait est que ce ministre ce ministère
pardon de la santé et tout c'est
tentacules est tellement gigantesques
que s'il n'y avait qu'une seule fusible
des adaptabilité c'est à dire le
ministre et bien nos ministes la santé
ne resterait pas souvent en place la
machine est tellement gros cela alors je
mettrais ce bémol l'eau
de manière générale j'avoue que le
rapport final de la carnoy moi un peu
réconcilié avec le processus j'ai ça
m'agaçait un petit peu personnellement
moi cette démarche après coup de
maintenant qu'on sait ce qui est arrivé
maintenant qu'on connaît mieux la
pandémie qu'on connaît comment ce virus
se comportaient il ya quelque chose d'un
peu facile parfois de retourner en
arrière puis dire mon dieu on aurait
donc vu se protéger plus le chcd mois
les hôpitaux il y avait quelque chose
d'un peu agaçant là dedans et je trouve
qu'elle est la grenade éviter cet écueil
là en étant quand même plus posée dans
sa répartition de rands 1 comprenant lé
contexte elle ne convainc qu'on voit
qu'elle a écouté pas mal de monde devant
être elle avait un portrait général oui
très bien
monsieur legault on reste sur monsieur
legault il a voulu aujourd'hui on a vu
la manifestation de certaines personnes
anglophones et d'autres il y avait des
francophones également montréal contre
le projet de loi 96 les cgp inquiète
d'autres éléments qui inquiète aussi
dans le projet de loi 85 monsieur
legault avait ce message à la communauté
anglophone
qui aussi la désinformation concernant
les services de santé parce que la loi
96 ne change absolument rien sur le
guest qu'on a comme gouvernement donnait
des services en a un que les mêmes aux
nouveaux arrivants people justin clé est
donc rien de changé ce côté là puis dans
les cgv mais quand je disais les
anglophones représentent 9% de la
population
7 % des places c'est prévu dans le
projet de 96 que les anglophones vont
avoir priorité pour ces places là
alors il a voulu aujourd'hui rassurer la
communauté anglophone à tulle marquer
des points et l'udc
oui là dessus parce que c'est un pourri
qui faisaient beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
de bruit sur internet dans les réseaux
sociaux aux émotions pour eux mêmes
puissent faire soigner et même y en a
qui évoquait la possibilité que des
inspecteurs puissent exiger des médecins
et qu'il parle en français à l'heure
qu'il y a il faisait aucun sens mais en
règle générale il faut dire que il y à
une minorité agissante côté des
smartphones qui fait d'eux des pressions
comme pour la loi 101 pour indiquer
toute progression du français vont nous
éliminer toute progression de français
étaient justifiées nous avons fait tous
les efforts nécessaires et donc faire
paraître le gouvernement le goût comme
un monstre en la matière
évidemment que ça va ça va durer encore
pendant des années tout renforcement des
lois au québec la loi si on était honni
la loi 96 vont l'être tout autant
christian et expliquer pourquoi il
n'allait pas participer au débat
anglophone lors de la prochaine campagne
en disant un que ça lui mangeait trop de
take 2 la langue française est la langue
du et là est la langue officielle du
québec pour aller qu'en pensez vous
voilà par la commune il s'agit vraiment
sur cette position là un peu par rapport
aux autres qui ont commencé ses souhaits
fait que l'anglais quand même très
important tout aussi le fait que c'est
quelqu'un qui est pas totalement à
l'aise en anglais à jouer je le sais pas
mais moi je résume revenir sur le jeu
doit linguistique parce qu'il semble que
l'udc a raison quand on touche à la
langue c'est forcément un peu
controversé mais ça peut d'échec pour
monsieur vous parce que lui il aurait
bien voulu que tout ça se passe un truc
controverse avec un bon consensus et est
arrivé ce que je craignais moi je dois
lui refusant en fait de faire preuve
d'un peu d'audace et de vision
d'appliquer la loi 101 au cégep s'y
arrêter controversé mixeur été clair et
simple là il s'est enlisé dans le tatami
nages ça fait penser à l'époque le savez
quand on mesurait la grandeur des
lettres le capitole danse du français
les deux tiers librement lisais dans
quelque chose où il est perdant par ce
qui est sur la défensive ces techniques
et moi je trouve qu'ils payent le prix
ça aurait été beaucoup simple les
pression était énorme cet impôt
dépression juge démagogique carlton le
professeur de cégep que tu sais ça qu'il
faut faire si j'avais fait ça il y
aurait une tante revers ce mois qu'il
serait pas où il s'est réalisé qu'il est
actuellement parce qu'il est enlisée
puis c'est pas un gros souci pour
monsieur le groupe parce qu il voulait
éviter la controverse puis pour taylor
et ben ouais on va revenir se mêler de
manière générale comment vous voyez
cette relation entre la communauté
anglophone et le gouvernement de l'ancac
est ce que monsieur legault a du chemin
à faire pour rassurer les gens
oui visiblement concours ne lui fait pas
confiance mais sans vouloir sonner trop
cynique je ne suis pas certaine que ce
soit un échec pour le gouvernement de la
cac il y as peut-être un avantage
partisans électorale à la situation
actuelle qui comme ça crée une
polarisation linguistique ce qui n'est
pas bon c'est pour ça je veux pas avoir
l'air cynique mais qui al'avantage de
nuire au parti libéral qui suit bêtement
se fait menacer par ces deux autres
petits partis anglophones qui pourrait
venir lui dirigé gruger son vote et
monsieur legault en étant dans la
position de celui qui défend sa loi à
l'air d'être le nationalisme du groupe
celui qui se porte à la défense de la
majorité francophone et donc ça pourrait
être vu quand même positivement par une
certaine majorité alors je pense que
d'un point de vue strictement le calcul
politique peut-être qu'il gagne quelque
chose de cette situation même si au
niveau de la paix sociale c'est
certainement pas une bonne chose ça
allait en fait ce qu'il a dit même plus
tôt aujourd'hui je suis la voie du
milieu les libéraux voudraient qu'il n'y
a pas de qu'on ne
limite pas le nombre de places dans les
cégeps anglophones le parti québécois
veut ce que monsieur ce que christian
vous disiez c'est à dire on ferme
l'accès aux francophones et aux
allophones au cégep anglophone lui dis
moi je suis au milieu les places
actuelles on les garde mais pas plus pas
moins mais pas sûr mais permettez je
trouve qu'on n'avait pas vraiment besoin
de ce genre de débat le bon parce qu
elle n 10 bat sur un plan strictement
partisan peut-être qu'il gagne mais
monsieur vous aurez pas besoin de ça en
fait parce que tu te dis qu'il va gagner
prochaines élections je pense qu'ils
auraient peut-être s'arrêter du meilleur
pour tout le monde que ça se fasse de
façon plus consensuelle pas totalement
consensuel mais là on n'est pas dans le
consensus la manifestation en fin de
semaine mais beaucoup de démagogie c'est
un drame parce
c'est pas si un jeune francophone veut
aller étudier à dawson qui par ailleurs
un français impeccable qui veut
améliorer son anglais harry veut ouvrir
d'autres horizons c'est pas maintenant
de lui dire non aussi à l'udc mais oui
oui c'est vrai que pour une personne
c'est anna ya des cas individuels comme
ça où tu dis mais pourquoi sauf que
quand tu regardes le collectif et que tu
t'aperçois que le poids du cégep dawson
désiré par personne c'est 50% pour une
population qui représente même pôle le
septième de sa marche pas ça fonctionne
pas le problème de la loi mon avis 96
c'est une loi sans solution c'est à dire
que l vous vexer des anglophones mais ne
va pas améliorer le fait français au
québec parce que le fait français au
québec est menacé par bien plus que les
cégeps bien plus que l'insolence à
certains anglophones qui disent moi je
m'en fous du français puis je veux pas
de la porte et elle est menacée par
c'est la langue du dealer de l'anglais
la langue divertissement la langue du
travail la langue de l'internet la
langue des médias et et les mesures qui
sont prises là c'est une accumulation de
petites mesures qui n'arriveront pas à
changer cet état de fait les bons hélène
parlant de la langue il ya un texte sur
notre site notre collègue qui a sorti
des chiffres sur le nombre de sous
ministres francophones par rapport au
sous ministre anglophone gouvernement
fédéral et 81 pour ça des sous ministres
sont en fait plus on monte si je veux
résumer grossièrement moyen de
francophones et la
wii c'est tizi faut quand même préciser
que les sous ministres sont tous plus ou
moins bilingues là en fait c'est plutôt
leur origine linguistique et qui compte
effectivement mais je suis presque
étonné qu'on soit étonné de ces
informations leur salut j'habite ici
dans la région
d'ottawa-gatineau et si une chose que
tous mes amis fonctionnaires
dis toujours c'est que la fonction
publique canadienne n est pas bilingue
c'est une fonction publique qui est
traduite les choses se passent en
anglais et ensuite on traduit les mémos
afin de donner cette impression cette
façade de bilinguisme j'ai des amis
fonctionnaires qui par exemple lorsque
nouveau programme nouvelle politique est
mise en oeuvre et qu'on fait des séances
d'information pour les expliquer aux
travailleurs la différence en anglais et
en français et même les francophones
s'inscrivent aux séances anglaise parce
que c'est là qu'elles vont apprendre et
qui vont apprendre le vocabulaire lié à
cette politique là les acronymes et donc
sachant que tout va se passe en anglais
dans un futur il est mieux apprendre
tout seul jean-paul le pourcentage parce
qu'on est un peu en dessous les
francophones sont à deux genoux de leur
nombre
des blessés légers à 2 19 % versus le
poids réel dans la population qui était
à peu près de 23% mais sachez que les
anglophones eux se critiquent
constamment l' inverse c'est à dire que
dans le reste la fonction publique et 31
% de francophones ce qui est beaucoup
plus que le nombre de francophones au
canada christian petit mot là-dessus
mais je trouve que c'était très
intéressant cet article lorsque j'ai
appris vraiment des choses ne changent
pas venu que 31% des fils honneur
fédéraux sous francophone alors que les
francophones sont juste 23 % de la
population 28% des cas sont francophones
moi c'est des choses qui est ce que
j'irai donc évidemment ça fait ressortir
le fait que au niveau le plus élevé au
niveau des souliers sont des timbres du
pourcentage de
leur est plutôt bon bah c'est plus tu
mens assez qu'on pourrait le penser de
prime abord comme comme le dit elle elle
les sous ministres sont bilingues
puissants ils peuvent comprendre le
français puis on dénombre
peut-être je vais vous parler du prince
charles je vous prédis l'udc je commence
avec vont voir des images arrivé à
terre-neuve villa je pense qu'il a même
goûté une bière fait avec de l'audace
berg et toute une programmation a subi
si nos joueurs derrière dit là-dessus ce
matin accueilli par le premier ministre
par la gouverneure générale etc saint
jean alors et ça vous inspire quoi
luc hélène et christian luc
premièrement la monarchie n'a aucun
impact sur le canal de la seule raison
pour laquelle on tolère système
monarchique là c'est qu'il est tellement
insignifiant entre guillemets c'est à
dire si peu significatif il n'a pas
d'impact sur nos vies alors autant là
mais l'australie la nouvelle-zélande ont
l'intention de s'en débarrasser après le
décès de la lahb la reine elizabeth ii 2
il ya le deux tiers des pays du
commonwealth qui s'en sont débarrassés
satire sont devenus des républiques
alors il va rester nous et puis
l'angleterre pourquoi nous on reste là
dedans mystère et boule de gomme
j'entends pas les canadiens se
revendique la monarchie j'entends pas
une culture de la monarchie ou des
valeurs monarchie au canada je vous
montrais des chiffres je donne la parole
à hélène au canada est ce que le canada
devrait rester une monarchie
conditionnelle oui non incertain et au
québec effectivement il n'ya pas même au
canada ça ça peut dans tout le canada 26
oui ontario 30/2 québec en 71 est assez
claire au québec ln oui mais en fait
s'il n'ya pas tant de mystère et boule
ugg que ça vous donneront de
l'expression de l'udc est gentiment la
raison pour laquelle on s'en débarrasse
peau parce qu'effectivement c'est vrai
qu'elle n'est pas très effective
c'est parce que c'est coincé dans notre
constitution pour changer cet aspect de
l'acompte de notre structure
gouvernementale il faudrait l'appui des
dix provinces le sénat et la chambre des
communes donc c'est toujours quand on
commence à parler constitution tout le
monde arrive à la table avec ses propres
demandes revendications et c'est pour ça
que ça n'avance pas et on peut pas juste
de claques en un claquement de doigts
pardon dire que ça disparaît même si ça
n'a pas d'impact dans notre vie
quotidienne toutes nos lois sont deux
structures est formé de manière telle
qu'on a besoin d'un sanctioner quelqu'un
qui donne son aval à une multitude de
décisions et se sanctionnent carlo c'est
la gouverneure générale sera chef de
temps on est dans une charmante un vrai
chef des fauchages et la conscience soit
devenue une région dire soit alors
christian où en êtes vous aujourd'hui
seule la monarchie
russell des seuls francophones québécois
qu'une certaine sympathie pour la
monarchie britannique j'assume mais
comme le dit hélène comme le dit hélène
en fait c'est très difficile de changer
ça pour système des bottes pour être
très difficile c'est vrai que la
majorité des canadiens aimeraient qu'on
passe à autre chose mais il ya une
minorité pour qui ça peut être important
c'est pas très grave mais qu est-ce qu
on est au niveau des symboles moi je
vais vous avouer que je préfère un
prince charles qui parlent bien ma
langue maternelle le français qu'une
gouverneur général en fait que massacrer
la langue maternelle lors du discours
inaugural la reine d'angleterre elle
plane aussi un excellent à froid c'est
donc moi ce sont des choses qui me
touchent comme tel et choisir que
j'attache et moi aux sessions politique
britannique
bree tanner je sais qu'au québec je peux
le comprendre à cause de la conquête
c'est que la conquête a eu un côté
oppressant qui est encore là les gars
c'était une fécondation aussi et ç'a
aidé ou pouvoir québécois jeu très
sensibles à ça donc je partage pas
l'espèce de vision très manichéenne des
francophones à l'égard de distin
britannique ça et des pouvoirs québécois
ça a aidé le poids francophone et la
reine d'angleterre je trouve que c'est
une grande dame
est d'autant que techniquement comme dit
hélène c'est pas si simple à remplacer
le cpom
mystère et boule de neige possibles
il faut trouver un système qui va
fonctionner oui d'accord mais des
changements constitutionnels au prochain
changement constitutionnel autre formule
est-ce qu'on pourrait le mettre en
parallèle au prochain changement
constitutionnel voici les exigences de
l'abolition de la monarchie voici ce que
cela exigerait alors est-ce que la nar à
une prochaine ronde conditionnelle je ne
sais pas car ça lui
[Musique]